أوروبا هي حديقة
قمنا ببنائها حديقة كل شيء يعمل
هو أفضل مزيج من الحرية السياسية
والازدهار الاقتصادي والتماسك الاجتماعي
الذي تمكنت البشرية من
بناء ثلاثة أشياء
معًا بقية العالم وأنت تعلم
جيدًا أن فيديريكا ليست بالضبط
حديقة بقية العالم معظم
بقية العالم هي
الغابة والغابة
يمكن أن تغزو الحديقة
ويجب على البستانيين
الاعتناء بها للعناية بالحديقة لكنهم
لن يحميوا الحديقة بالجدران من خلال
بناء الجدران  حديقة صغيرة لطيفة
محاطة بجدران عالية من أجل
منع
دخول الغابة لن تكون
حلاً لأن الغابة لديها
قدرة نمو قوية ولن يكون العالم
مرتفعًا بما يكفي
لحماية الحديقة التي يجب
على البستانيين القيام بها  اذهب إلى الغابة
، يجب أن يكون الأوروبيون أكثر
انخراطًا مع
بقية العالم وإلا سيغزونا بقية العالم